yo yo it's DJ rock steady with paper out
Empire you can catch me right here on
the bootleg kale podcast let's go
bootle cat podcast we live from AZ big
game weekend shout out to Def Jam shout
out to Remy
also shout out to my guy DJ Rocksteady
yo paper
we here yes sir welcome man hey so we
got a dope thing going on in AZ this
whole weekend
um
you've been well shout out to paper
route because there's the dolphin pop-up
Museum that's been traveling all over
the country yeah oh yeah and uh you guys
already to Denver right yeah we do la we
did LA we did New York City we did
Dallas wow how many cities is it gonna
hit man look here I can't even I don't
even have an answer for you it's like
it's literally like it is it really is a
pop-up you know right so we're not
planned we're adding cities like at
random right now so I tell people like
listen just because you don't see your
city you know what I'm saying don't mean
it's not coming don't mean it's not
coming yeah so what was the uh kind of
like the idea and the thought process
towards obviously paying homage I mean
to Dolph who is not physically here with
us anymore but is still very prevalent
in our culture there's the new album
that just came out most definitely yeah
paper airplane the album out right now
which is doing um extremely well yeah
I'm saying like it's yo I mean it's all
dope you know what I'm saying it's him
even the museum it's like it's him like
we really like we're working through him
and you know doctor's a legend you know
what I'm saying like you know that about
it like he One of a Kind you're a genius
you know what I'm saying so like I mean
the world needs to know you know what
I'm saying like his fans I mean like are
just the greatest fans in the world like
they come out from all over to support
and yeah some some people actually never
got a chance to see him live in concert
so like them coming to the museum is
like they get to feel like they're
getting close you know what I'm saying
though it's crazy because I just got
like on Instagram now on stories they
have like memories yeah and uh I just
got a memory pop-up on my story
it was like two or three years three
years ago today that dolphin Glock were
in La for the tour at uh what was the
venue they did in La it was the uh the
wheelchair oh yeah that [__] was crazy
it was like literally today was the
three year anniversary popped up I was
like oh [__] crazy legendary tour if you
did not get to see that tour I feel like
that was a little books for show both of
those guys and they come out back
together on stage it was legendary dude
um so like for you man uh I mean I met
you with Dolph probably in 2013 or 14
when I was in Tampa yeah most definitely
Tampa we uh Dolph had just released um
king of Memphis album yeah which which
is one of my favorites yeah that
interview went up to us that's the one
that has
what's the one uh was is royalty on yeah
royalties on there royalties might
that's my favorite dog song most
definitely yeah no that was a that was a
crazy it's crazy too because like
living in the South like I don't think
people who maybe are from other cities
or from other regions of the country
understand like the reach that Dolph had
or just like what his music means to so
many people because like um La New York
obviously there's fans he sells on shows
but I feel like the cultural impact of
someone like young Dolph is not fully
appreciated unless you're like nearby
where he's from you know what I mean is
that fair uh not what man not not really
man because we got support just come
from like
I mean when he was alive like that that
time period like 2013 2014 2015 yeah
like to be in Florida yeah Dolph had it
like it felt different you know most
definitely and and to be honest kid like
I don't even like like with doves like
his supporters like I don't even like
using the word fans right because it
like it Waters it down to me like like
it's on some industry [__] and it's like
it's not what it is like the people that
come out they're like really supported
like they family like like for real for
real you know what I'm saying like man
they paper out they gang gang for sure
the ones they like tattoos yeah they
they man super super supporters and I
think the difference is it's just like
he never had a machine bro you know what
I'm saying we never had a machine so
like the people that supported Dolph
like whether they whether they bought
the album or they bought tickets to the
concert about merch like they so like
they support they helped build this
thing
they're still going like they're a part
of it like so it's not like I don't even
like using the word fans but you got
some huge supporters and it's like they
come out and it's just it's been love
bro give me uh give me like your top or
give me a crazy
DJing for Dolph tour story because
you've been at festivals you've done the
tours and then you've also probably done
the craziest small town pick up a brown
bag type of situations at a nightclub
like give me like a crazy night with
Dolph that you can like kind of reflect
on now that is just like probably okay
like probably like one of the like most
memorable for me would be like us just
starting out like really you know
working the small markers and I can
remember this one time
these guys booked us and I don't and
please forgive me because I forget who
the promoters were but we had some
promoters book us in East St Louis oh
and Illinois you know and everybody if
you know about St Louis like East Saint
like he's saying is where things get
hairy yeah yeah for real for real it's
on the other side of the state line most
definitely so in these guys
like obviously we pull up you know what
I'm saying and we pull up to the venue
we excited we got a show but it's dead
bro you know what I'm saying it's dead
and it's not dead because dog not
buzzing is dead because like these
promoters really wasn't promoters like
these were Street [__] like they were
they were like like they like they were
streaming like they just loved off right
like they just wanted to you know what
I'm saying about like when I get with
him we like bro he like hey yo they
spent that money bro we gonna give him a
show and we gave him a full show and
it's really just them like they just
wanted to see him so they almost like
booked him just so they could get a
personal concert with most differently
in East St Louis in East St Louis like
for real so man and it just and it
always just stuck with me like oh that's
how much of a grass we had on the
streets it's just like and if you're a
professional too like hey yo they paid
yeah most definitely like you could have
walked out of me like nah this ain't it
this ain't the look or whatever or not
but Rosie you stayed we kicked it you
know what I'm saying and and touched
everybody that was there so it was love
sorry is one of my most memorable like
even though we've been all over with it
and you know sure what's like obviously
what is the the Necessities for when you
guys would tour like what would Dolph
like need in the dressing room or what
would something that like was I always
hear socks draws all that kind of shit's
like normal [__] for touring but like
you guys are on the road you're hitting
East St Louis you're hitting you know
random cities in Georgia random places
in Ohio I'm sure like what's like
something y'all needed in every city you
know what dog not it wasn't really
difficult like brought one of his
Backwoods and he wanted a fruit tray you
know what I'm saying and he wanted his
cheese and crackers and that was like
that was it he didn't really require a
lot like Crisis you would think he
probably would you know what I'm saying
his rider wasn't ridiculous at all like
he just he just wanted his little zuzus
and went wings and he was good what's up
guys hey shout out to our family at uh
Bluetooth man listen I know we always
are getting feedback about our Bluetooth
interviews
they're not interviews yeah they're
commercials and we're always getting
feedback about them usually it's they're
[__] hilarious man
you know people love it when we talk
about Bluetooth but let me say this [__]
works a lot of people are like look man
I see you talking about Bluetooth but
does it work yes it works if y'all don't
know Bluetooth it's got the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis but in a
chewable form it's delivered to your
door
in a discrete package and you don't have
to go inside of a doctor's office to get
it no awkward doctor visits involved
everything is online that's right you go
to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg they will send you a month for
free a month supply of Bluetooth for
free five dollar shipping that's it and
they'll be like damn Kev
you were right bro my erections are lit
as they should be every
erection should be
as erect as possible you know you don't
want to be flaccid you don't want to be
one of those 70 30 guys you know that
means that 30 of your dicks potentially
hardness is being uh
underutilized
could you use an extra 30 hard maybe 50
hard I don't know it depends on what
you're dealing with they're dealing with
stress in your life
are you tired of having sex with your
girlfriend
hard to get it up well go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg they're going to send you a
month for free they also just drop the
mint chewable same active ingredient as
Levitra that's right so what you need to
do
I mean you don't need to do anything if
you want to you know not be as hard as
you can be that's on you but
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
and try it for free a month supply free
delivered to your door no awkward doctor
appointment needed it's all online all
right bluetooth.com
also want to shout out to our family
over at Odd Socks that's right as
someone who wears Odd Socks every day
I'll prove it to you
I'm in Arizona right now this is just
random
we got The Odd Socks underwear right
there I mean that's Odd Socks and we got
the hot sauce Basics baby yeah so look
so this was stuff about Odd Socks man
um not only do they got the most
comfortable socks in the world because
they do I'm not just saying that because
they sponsor our show it's true uh they
also got some of the crazy licenses they
just got Coca-Cola uh they got Doritos
they got [__] everything they got
Scarface Godfather
uh Breaking Bad WWE we can go on and on
and on underwear socks slippers hats all
kinds of cool stuff
oddsoxofficial.com right now use the
promo code bootleg and you will save 20
off at checkout try the Odd Socks Basics
if you're one of those guys who wears
other plain white branded socks plain
black socks I promise you go with the
odd Sox basics
and you will believe me but just you
will convert over they're way more
comfortable
they're way more durable
and they just they're Odd Socks why
would you wear those other socks we
could wear on socks bro stand out and be
odd go to oddsocksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview
uh for you guys putting together this
Museum had to probably there's a big
responsibility in that right because
you're asking fans to come out you
represent him how much was
uh Dolph's wife involved in like maybe
curating or helping maybe add items to
the museum like in terms of just because
like when you go to a museum I feel like
there's got to be like yo I don't know
what's in there I'm going tonight but
like you're gonna see it you're gonna
you're gonna love it um yeah she most
definitely like like one thing not only
her but just the family and most
definitely being very intentional to try
to be respectful you know what I'm
saying it's possible not not only for
the um for dogs you know what I'm saying
not only for for his wife and his in his
his family but even the supporters the
fans just want everybody like you know
to be respectful as as we possibly can
with with this Legacy because this is
important this is you know it's a big
deal you know what I mean like make sure
we tell the story right and make sure we
you know portray him how he will want to
be portrayed if he was here so they most
definitely have you know all of his
family just came and checked it out and
put input on it and you know we've made
adjustments where we need to make
adjustments but you know overall like
your man oh it's it's lit bro it's lit
like it's a real experience for the
culture like this something that you
have to see like you just you got to see
it and once you're in it like you feel
it
do you have a copy of this rookie card
for John Morant or dolphin Glock in the
background no I don't I need to get away
in this crazy because just being on even
when um um I went out on Glocks last
tour Yellow Tape tour and he actually
had a few fans actually like bringing
that card and he signed it oh yeah
that'd be crazy to have yeah so that's
like yeah it's missing from my
collection but anyway I'm gonna get one
for you man like from your perspective
without diving into anything too much
but like Memphis feels like historically
it's been one of the more divided
hip-hop communities I don't know if
uh it feels like lately that there's a
lot more positivity like I feel like a
guy like Emily Choppa is somebody who's
definitely good lead man shout out hit
kid I mean it's a lot like Memphis got a
lot of talent and it's a lot of new you
know what I'm saying New Generation it's
crazy I was just having this
conversation
um with his kid the other day and I was
just telling him like he just brought a
slime moroney on the show recently oh DD
dope yeah yeah dope dope and I was you
know I was telling him because like you
know we were just discussing the whole
king of Memphis
um you know this era this thing right
you know what I'm saying and like
and when you interviewed off like you
know he'd be like man he broke it down
like king of Memphis it's not saying hey
I'm king of Memphis all y'all like up
under me know he's like man yo we all
Kings like man everybody's a king like
you handle your business so so and dog's
whole mission was to show people that
hey if I can do it man you can do it too
and you can probably do it better than
I did it like he wanted that like he
embraced it you know what I'm saying
like he he want all his artists to be
bigger and better than him you know I'm
saying he won't and even if you're not
his artist he still wants you to be
bigger you know what I'm saying and
better like because he understood like
it's it is most definitely is enough for
everybody to go go around yeah I feel
like when he made that that I mean
obviously put the album out but I feel
like yeah it's the same thing like like
when TI said he was the King of the
South people were like what the [__] who
is this guy this was like TI was saying
that [__] very early yeah most
definitely you know you know TI was
saying it he most definitely was but
somebody should like say my thing is
just like like you said like with
dolphins like
he proclaimed it nobody else is going to
Proclaim it and who's going to tell them
different at that time like what are we
talking about I think his philosophy was
just different about it though it wasn't
still like it wasn't for me
it's just like hey you know I'm a king
in Memphis because most definitely yo
shout out to those before us man ball
and G like they're Kings of Memphis
juicy and Kings of Memphis man RP
Gangsta Boo she a queen of Memphis you
know big loss too man [__] man Memphis
has had a rough too I just yeah cause
gangsta boo man she was uh she was a
Pioneer for sure was a good friend you
know what I'm saying very like to really
know her like if you don't know her you
just you think she hard and she just
gangsters to the core but if you really
know her man she just got such a sweet
Soul she like a sweet person like in
real life like for real how hard has it
been for you man being
um you know and I was I was close with
Dolph obviously he was a homie man it's
crazy because him and I talked
two or three days before he passed um
about Glock yeah and he was like I need
to get Glock on the show he's about to
you know get his [__] together and I was
like and I told him I told us to to
Glock I was like me and Dolph talked
because I've interviewed Glock before
yeah Dolph was behind the camera and
this was like before Glock I think
really kind of was comfortable talking
and he didn't really know me yeah so it
was like a bad interview you know what I
mean like he was like one word answers
and I remember the last combo I had with
Dolph was like bro please talk to him
because he's a star but you we gotta we
gotta get hit like we get you what you
got to understand about Glock man like
he a real deal
we just had a great interview yeah but
that was my last combo with Dolph but I
was gonna actually like dolphins my guy
man like him and I were super tight like
but he was your brother you know what
I'm saying so I know what it felt like
losing him just from like somebody who
was like uh industry friend yeah you
know what I mean working with Empire and
and I was in uh Las Vegas for the Latin
Grammys around Ghazi when when it
happened in November you know and uh but
how have you been able to kind of it's
been a year you know
um I can't imagine
being in your shoes and losing someone
like dolphin I mean it hurt bro yeah I
can't fake it it hurt you know what I'm
saying like we did everything together
but at the at the end of the day like
Dolph like
he just so he just
he's just such a Visionary like bro just
would always say like man we got to keep
this we got to keep this rolling like
you know I'm saying yo it was one day
whenever I'm gone like this is gonna
continue to roll you know what I'm
saying like and you always say like
um
you know like don't know this [__] mean
nothing like this money this jewelry
this cars it's like this [__] don't mean
nothing you know what I'm saying like
that ain't what life about so like
seeing him like just the impact that
he's made like on the coaching on the
world like on the on the hood like today
and that's what it's about Legacy right
you know what I'm saying like that's
what it's about so we're gonna honor
that and we're gonna you know what I'm
saying like we got a lifelong commitment
when we say you know I'm saying PR E5
life like this you know what I'm saying
like we mean it you know you don't stand
on it right what's up y'all bootleg Kev
here hey look my bookie man it's a big
weekend in sports the big game is Sunday
Chiefs versus Eagles I'm all in on the
Eagles
I like Jalen hurts over on the passing
yards over on the rushing yards anytime
touchdown score give me Dallas got her
anytime touchdown score give me the over
and if anyone on the Chiefs is going to
score I like that Pacheco kid I like the
little running back guy and of course
you gotta Hammer Travis Kelsey anytime
touchdown score you could do all that at
my bookie right now all right so many
props to bet on at my bookie this
weekend you can bet on the Gatorade
color that gets poured out you could bet
on the on the flip the the coin flip at
the beginning of the game all that right
now at my bookie sign up with the promo
code bootleg when you sign up they will
match your very first deposit up to one
thousand dollars with that promo code
bootleg so go to mybookie.ag sign up for
an account
promo code bootleg whatever you put in
they're gonna double it
as long as it's not more than a thousand
you put 999 dollars in they're gonna
give you another 9.99
you put a thousand in they gave you
another thousand by the way if you do
the 9.99 why not just do the full
thousand you cheap bastard anyway my
bookie right now man it's a big weekend
also I just would like to point out
everyone should be putting some of that
money sprinkling a little bit of that
action on the Phoenix Suns win the
championship this year because we have
Kevin Durant oh yeah oh yeah my bookie
sign up with that promo code bootleg
also shout out to our family at hardean
Harding Las Vegas Yes you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
a customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with hard
Dean you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot
them a follow on Instagram while you're
at it go to their website
hardinglasvegas.com so much fly gear so
much fly weed what are we talking about
baby shout out to hardine man that's the
family man go if you're in Vegas pull up
on them man Jardine Las Vegas
from your perspective what do you think
um
is
the missing component to like having
real unity in Memphis or do you think
it's just not possible
I'm gonna say in that I'm not gonna say
is um it's not possible you know but we
we you know we we do have some that are
stuck in their ways and I think it's
going to most definitely take you know
us embracing the new newer generation
and you know what I'm saying it's so
much talent in the city and and like
not holding you know what I'm saying not
not holding resources away or not like
not helping one another you feel what
I'm saying like we got to open it up
like we gotta like this they're like
this on the city right now you know what
I'm saying like I feel real good about
it like
you know it may look a certain way on
the outside looking in but man we got
it's a lot of good stuff going on in the
city yeah I feel like it's the biggest I
mean I would I always say Memphis and I
feel like Detroit is on its way up too
Memphis I feel like got it right right
now Memphis got this [__] I was telling
somebody else there too like to watch
out Detroit the Detroit's gonna come on
it's going to come up for sure for sure
everybody's signing somebody from
Detroit yeah and Detroit's on Fire Man
shout out to everybody from Detroit
um for you as a DJ man like
you know just on some DJ [__] like
you know being an artist DJ is very uh
you get a lot of responsibility you got
to kind of be you sometimes you got to
be the grown-up you don't wear a lot of
hits you gotta wear a lot of hats you
kind of you're kind of a security guard
too you got a tour manager you know you
do a lot of [__] I'm sure yeah we'll get
it done everyone picks up the slack on
the team but for you now like uh you
know just on some DJ [__] like what what
is what are what is like your thing are
you gigging are you doing clubs like
what are you doing right now just I'm
doing I'm doing I'm doing clubs I'm here
and there most definitely like
celebrating
um you know the release of paper out
Frank you know I'm saying dos album so
you know I step out I'm stepping out on
on behalf of Dolph every time I um I pop
out then of course it is what it is
um you know what I'm saying as far as
that but for the most part just I mean
overseeing a lot of day-to-day
operations with the label just making
sure everything is running how it's
supposed to run so man we can do what we
need to do that stuff so you're you're
now you're now helping with the
operations on the label side yeah most
definitely I wish I wish I always
have man you know what I'm saying but I
think it's just more kind of out on the
Forefront now because people kind of see
like this what's going on like I'm a
character continue to carry the toys for
my brother so
how much unreleased golf music is there
because he recorded a very high pace so
I cannot imagine paper route fake is not
going to be the last Dolph album here I
can't speak on it right now Kim I don't
know I just know it was paper route
Frank the album out right now it's all
like that's that's all I know that's all
I'm gonna speak on right now like who
you know who knows number three in the
can who knows what I'm pretty sure being
me and Glock talked about it he said it
wasn't the can I'm pretty sure that's is
that already out in the air weren't you
there he was there I don't know like I
don't know I don't know you got days
Glock about about a dumb and done with
three I just know paper route Frank the
album young Dolph is out right now it's
going crazy so if people want to go to
the museum or they want to see if it's
coming like are you guys updating it on
a website or is it just on the pre-ig or
like where can people see if it's if
it's on the way definitely most
definitely um stay tapped in on
youngdove.com
um for dates and times and um and
tickets you can also uh keep up with
um um Doc's Instagrams the status
um running his profile you know paid so
they'll keep everything updated as far
as as far as that goes but yeah man we
just have really just having fun with it
like I only nobody never even did this
before like it's new it's new especially
just like paying homage to you know it
gives fans uh
an opportunity to
you know still
be a part of golf after he's not here
you know what I mean because it's like
man the album's out it's like damn I
can't go see him live you know there's
like that that that element's missing so
it's good to know that fans can still go
support the family support Dolph and
still get kind of a piece of them get a
look behind the curtain yeah my mom's
definitely like pull up ain't we having
a good time man we having a good time
each and every time like it's we not we
ain't on no sad [__] or nothing like we
coming through and we putting on we're
putting on for paper airplane for show
like man it's a I'm telling you it's a
Vibe here you gonna see I'm gonna be
there tonight man paper route Frank uh
the album is out
Golfland the museum
and AZ all weekend
and maybe coming to a city near you yeah
maybe coming to a city near you my bro I
appreciate you pulling up it's all love
kill boom